vibrate off proof mmm I have to keep to
always tell my vibrate off oh this is it
Oh cuz you keep on the tape I leave on
the table and we live we're live with
our [ __ ] live in five
oh [ __ ] Bob so I'll let you know you go
first you go first
you cuz you said you're saying you
wanted to say to me yesterday yeah yeah
okay cool so and for the cadiz man on
the other end of the camera yeah so
obviously while we do this yeah it's
just me and you talking [ __ ] mmm I don't
know for sure I never know for sure what
the female perspective is yeah I just
know what I know in it I can only give a
guy's perspective on things so obviously
since we've been doing it I've just been
getting no end of messages from females
trying to put in there yeah yeah so it's
good so keep doing it if you've done it
keep doing it if you haven't done it
just do it so one girl messaged me
yesterday and actually no she didn't
message me she put sand on her store and
I laughed and then she said you can
explain that on your next podcast mmm so
she said it's basically guys being in
[ __ ] boys yeah I like mine Fox in it so
this was her
this was her story in it yeah I need to
I'll tell you what I'm actually gonna
screenshot it now so I can put it on the
video but it was what was it some
spongebob meme yeah
[Laughter]
that's funny so for those who are in
here on the video it's a spongebob meme
and basically is saying a guy Saints
will go don't catch feelings we're just
hooking up okay and her saying okay I
went on a date last night
hey man he's copied your sponge but we
made that little Jack out of his tears
brother what's you what's your for now
so my fault and that is its it boils
down to what I said yesterday about how
mundum have feelings as well you know I
mean obviously we like to play the game
about like in a in a sense of we we want
to bang we just wanna have fun I wanna
do tease want to do that we don't
necessarily catch reading so if we don't
want to show that we catch feelings yeah
because the balls in our core we feel
like we're in control yeah obviously if
she came with that rebuttal like ah I
went on a date yesterday anyway so it's
minor to me you're like hmm example
prime example the message I got
yesterday yesterday when I said I build
her and it's like ah I for surrounded
numbers I didn't have your number I
never saved you an ounce I've done
number anyway big man I saw you for two
months what do you mean never saved my
number oh he's not gonna say a name that
was the most one Road of insanity babe I
catch you on the street I'm [ __ ]
shanking you [ __ ]
we were dating for two months and you
never saved my number Jesus Christ oh my
god you women don't know what you do
they say we're a mindfuck firm you are
the [ __ ] you don't know what you do you
are the one [ __ ] with our minds it's
[ __ ] hilarious oh my god
never saved your number do you know do
you know what like why obviously
understand certain matters
I've got a lot of numbers not safe but
that's like people from work yeah only
gonna associate with in work I don't
yeah [ __ ] big man
I've been inside you multiple times save
my number fam save my number respect me
and respect yourself save - make me
enough to save my number yeah me much
disrespectful because I said you just
comes up obvious cause my own what's up
things FD so he said every time I
message just comes up a zeppole a lot
fair play but big man I never saved you
because I never I never called your face
town G but I didn't mean I didn't feel
the need saving I'm a big man what do
you mean cuz I'm on dates out shopping
told you Cooper see [ __ ] secretly she
didn't even save my normal game as long
this is a jungle out here phone I told
you see Chris brother and you never
saved my number
oh the jungle out here these streets
Brown mystery suburbs so yeah it's not
just guys that a mine [ __ ] man these
women play it savage they play it savage
oh so that's my perspective is as well
ways like I think I said I come over
I've said it [ __ ] me from my own
perspective in situation I've been in
that I laughed when I saw it because it
resonated like old [ __ ] boy James he's
been in that situation fam when I say I
want to be wanted that's all I wanted my
life is to be wanted and sometimes I
want to play the big like I don't even
know Billy big dick and I'm just like
yeah whatever and it's whatever to me
like this girl's gonna catch feelings
this girl's gonna catch for this is so
long everyone wants your boy in it but
like as soon as they confirm is like
nananana like they're just out how fun
yeah and they're seeing other people
rough my chest concave do that my
sternum crumbles fam what do you mean
you went on a date I'll dare you how
dare you use like I think the guys fear
is just being insignificant yeah a guy's
fears being is exhausting up at it to
her big man you and you're just one of
many fun that terrifies me no
yeah and but like we're confused this is
where girls are crazy but this in this
respect guys are crazy because like I
hate when I'm I want my cake I might eat
- from like the in the day I want to
[ __ ] around I want to be stupid
but I don't want you dating anyone else
but I also don't want to be your
everything you know I mean don't rely on
me don't rely on me if I live your life
in it
what big mundo de anyone else don't rely
on me but don't date anyone else cuz I'm
not bad to be disrespected in these
streams
save my number in it it's all a game
it's not a game so stupid the game is so
really is so rigged the game is so
[ __ ] rigged like [ __ ] what you heard
the game is rigged so yeah man I didn't
even have an answer for it guys our
headphones but women are [ __ ]
torturous bastards might when they want
to be
you can't tell a guy huh
you can tell a guy your interest in any
other guy cuz it's just heartbreaking
regardless if you guys are serious or
not never tell me you fancy someone fun
I will cut everyone yeah don't ever tell
me you fancy someone I remember I was
dating I was dating someone years ago
you remember his person obviously the
crazy one bash bash yeah yeah and then
she must have told me oh this is when we
were kind of off we're going on and off
station were kind of off and then she
just said to me with kampf that she saw
one guy out he was tall handsome big
charm in fancied the [ __ ] out of him
chatted to him exchanged numbers phone
she said it to me with confidence with
confidence and then I'm like big man
what and obviously I'm sucking two minds
I want to be like are you [ __ ] nuts
why the [ __ ] you telling me that and I'm
also want to be like ice miner I don't
really care that much I care every bit
if my heart was pounding BAM ah it's a
guy's nightmare to feel insignificant
it's a guy's [ __ ] nightmare girls must
feel at it every day then they actually
must because we feel that once in a blue
like yeah just say my limiting never
happens yes like that all the time
that's why they're always on edge and
like that's why they always want [ __ ]
what's the word I'm looking for they
want reinforcement reinforcement we on
about were you on about it's not
reinforcement we on about anyone
reassurance shut up shut up that's what
I meant reassurance in it
[Laughter]
yeah reassurance yeah you know where is
when you when I said when I said
reinforcement I was thinking of positive
reinforcement okay yeah yeah yeah that's
what I meant
that's what really is right but it's not
reinforcement cuz I couldn't forget a
word oh my god but yeah so that was that
was my one I don't have an answer for
the me me just it's always gonna happen
guys are [ __ ] idiots they're [ __ ]
boys and they yeah don't rely on me but
need me yeah don't want me yeah want me
don't need me yeah want me but when they
let me know that they don't need me
while I why be so cruel in it brav oh my
god men have feelings too I've done said
this before
men have feeling they know what me and
fury were talking about a little while
back it was situation so with me this
was time ago with me I need to be needed
not needed fam but like if I see you go
I like to go let's say we have sex
wherever and then I'm I'm actually
making the effort so for once it's not
just me paying off so
let's just say I've said what girls
before like you said before you don't
remember you don't even save that number
you just leave it you know it's gonna be
a one-night yeah yeah and then you have
one of these one night gigs mmm
but you're like ah this one was a little
bit all right I want to have a little a
day or whatever at all yeah and then you
actually put your feelers out and you're
like I wouldn't usually do this but
actually let me make an effort let me
try and date let's go
and you put it out there actually airs
you big man
so you [ __ ] [ __ ] watching James
Duncan with his heart on his sleeve and
I heard easy but if you're not down tell
me you know time from the jump down from
Remy don't string cuz I will act like a
crazy [ __ ] woman I will open your
whatsapp conversation and I'll keep it
if you've got an Amy I need to know
you're airing me just tell me you said
tell me so no go just tell me it's a
[ __ ] no go don't air me ah tell me
lies I was sleep in fact I was sleeping
sorry I was sleeping sorry I just got in
I was sleeping pick one life am pick one
light what do you mean you just got in
sorry I was sleeping
pick one [ __ ] lie bastards oh my god
but um yeah moving on moving the [ __ ] on
so talking about feedback from the
opposite sex
mmm we've had a development so obviously
we already know about situations so for
the viewers in episode 1 or 2 comer
which when it was we were talking about
being in a group chat like guys being in
the girls group chat and like talking
about small dicks sex and all of that
Retta
so I just got hit up from one of from a
girl saying let me go back to it she
said she's got a real life problem she's
like hahaha so been watching one of the
wait hold on [ __ ] off she's just type
side ass ah so I've been watching one
way you both want about small dicks or
being [ __ ] in bed and you're in a gossip
chat and then so my best mate texts me
this
mentioned and they remind me what you're
on about so that I'm gonna read the
message word-for-word oh my god this is
pleasant hey oh my god was it that bad
person B I'm not even exaggerating the
person a hilarious person B said real
problem because I actually liked him
he's really nice do I take the niceness
for a small dick but good at foreplay
this and that then just reminds me of
what you said if you do if you wanna
mend those faithful get a gap of a small
dick
proof is in the pudding well sometimes
in this person be again well sometimes
you got to do what's right and get with
him and get yourself a side man do
what's right do what's right ah
obviously I'm never gonna mention any of
the people's names it's just it's
affirmation that man de are in the group
shot from the jump so you have to always
perform you have to obviously got a
small dick man I can't do anything about
that and she said he's good at foreplay
but that clearly doesn't matter it's
irrelevant that's confirmation that's a
[ __ ] lie it doesn't make any sense
it's difference only where is that so
you man would have more to come [ __ ]
sorry I'm [ __ ] sorry I'm hot fooling
so last brother [ __ ] out the window it
makes no such thing as fanfare them man
no referral so referrals he's not
getting really eats good [ __ ] that's it
that was his foreplay was good but that
was the under sale firm his dick was
small she said why does he even bother
banging girls big man he must know he's
gonna be in the group chat big man
what's his name call me or any other yes
raise the dad Reni's Joe why does he
even bother banging goes bother why does
he bother why does he bother having sex
with people
[Laughter]
that's unacceptable why does he bother
have sex with people what do you mean
from I'm a human being I'm a human
[ __ ] being
what do you mean why do I bother having
sex with people uh so yeah as we said
before you always gotta put the work in
always gotta put there's not a second
chance to make a first impression facts
facts but we just had one of our female
friends over and we had a good chat mmm
guys if you listening that being said a
lot of [ __ ] women listen to this yeah
my analytics came back and for the last
week there's more women or for all the
audio obviously I don't know what the
like the video saying yeah pull that
thing up then it's gonna lean it's over
yeah it's fine yeah yeah so video I
don't know who the [ __ ] watching it
but yeah audio the Downloads all women
over the last seven days it's all been
women so guys if you're listening this
is the confirmation that we've had from
the opposite sex that said if you have a
[ __ ] day yeah
own it if you have a [ __ ] [ __ ] day
and you know you bus early or whatever
in the dick was [ __ ] and you know she's
disappointed cuz don't lie to yourselves
man you know you know when you've had a
[ __ ] no yeah everyone's had a [ __ ]
owned it but give it 12 hours go home
have a shower cool off
cool off send a girl a text or a voice
no and just be out babe babes voice no
they used to say no it's real boys know
she knows it's real you're owning it
probe babes
we both know last night didn't go to
plan let's not be coy get my name out
you [ __ ] group yeah and let's go for
round two round two I need to redeem us
I need a second chance at a first
impression because this isn't me that
was a few head you know what's up that
wasn't one I was being gassed you up for
weeks I wasn't me That's not me
give me another shot
yeah like they'll respect you man does
[ __ ] y'all think okay cool alright let's
go again then and then if you [ __ ] up
that time ah it's a racial [ __ ] that's
your business you have time to pray
about time you gave it a confident round
- oh yeah you see put your dick on a
pedestal now you better perform but hey
that's on you
that is on you band if you've got a
small dick confirmation there's only so
much Ian out you can do because foreplay
is clearly irrelevant right okay this is
I've got a question for any woman
listening I've got a [ __ ] question so
now we know you're liars
now the troops come out now the [ __ ]
truth has come out and all of this chat
about I had a go shot me last week and
say that like ah yeah I know what you
saying about the small dicks and stuff
like that but I've had a guy that like
it was really good and he had a small
dick and all that she was selling it
selling it said idea and then she
finished off the [ __ ] conversation by
saying that being said I do love a big
dick though erase everything you just
said and as I say that just say that so
now that we know you're [ __ ] liars
tell the truth if our guy's got a small
dick what option does he have he must
have an option fam he must have an
option for these man for these man Bravo
I don't know why it touches me like that
I just don't like because they know for
a fact there's nothing we can do about
it bro if there's nothing we can do
about it I say we buy MIT in depth of
nothing they can do about me mines
handle with care' yeah me yeah - Karma's
calm yeah if your dick is small like
ladies let us know what can those guys
do cuz clearly foreplay is just for big
just for players irrelevant until he
puts his piece in you from there elevate
until you [ __ ] speed yeah yeah
does he need to get nasty just need to
eat us yeah does he need know what the
[ __ ] him in the ass for you to feel
saying good could share that's the only
way he can rebut with a small dick
because not everyone hang on to love
anal you know I know everyone likes it
save he bangs you mini us then probably
that's that anyway you're gonna enjoy it
per se if you don't like anal but good
shout out so small D guys
anal soy did don't answer ladies don't
even ask lady but I've solved it spread
your cheeks let him [ __ ] don't answer
the question erase it we've solved it
anal there you go
it's the only way you can satisfy no
calm pleasurable pain that's it yeah man
yeah funny yeah yeah a man said
reinforcements shut up shut up ah yeah
so those were the two topics that we
discussed man it was scary scary the
reality of it scary is because you know
what's crazy like there's such a divide
mmm doing this podcast it made me
realize that there's such a [ __ ]
divide women love to chat [ __ ] and say
that no it's not all about big dicks yes
foreplay cancer and now we're not
obviously in the you know in a group
chat when you've had a [ __ ] time and
stuff like that and like oh if you
really care about the person that's your
fam yeah my girl said why does he bother
why does he bother having said she said
he's a nice guy she really likes him and
she he eats good [ __ ] the three ticks
three ticks but a dick and her response
was do what's right and get side man
girls are heartless cuz heartless but
we've got feelings whoa feelings out
here cuz that being said on a slight
side note let's come back to it but on a
slight side note if a girl messages me
like right here's the trick big man
here's the trick I love my man but I
love him and he treats me good I love
him to death but you got a hog on you
firm and he does it doesn't so I'm
trying to do what's right you better
[ __ ] me good and let me go home to my
man whoa my juices are flowing if you
tell me that flow we reinforce my dream
oh that's bang in no JoJo's ever gonna
say that same messages my phone and so I
need a side now were you saying I need a
big dick side man you say no report
nothing like you you've got nothing to
lose I'm just out here
I'm doing God's work I'm doing what's
best for the culture [ __ ] I'm going
door-to-door and only good Samaritan
I'm a [ __ ] Jehovah's Witness that's
why I hope you'll benefit in their
relationship Jesus Christ that your
marriage counselor you'll benefit in
their relationship by just giving good
pipe no feelings no girl could ever
message me our level ever I love that's
too sexy that's the sexy single of heard
that's too sexy the sexiest thing I've
ever heard
it's never gonna just made it up but it
is I would kill for that that was so low
do the right thing and get yourself a
side man it's just man like it's not
just mundum that are out here being
thugs brother you girls you girls are
nasty
you girls are nasty I got nasty with
what's the word I'm looking for
I don't even know the word you're sneaky
like you've got a hole man your goal
your goal is telling you get a side man
your breath real when you confided ah
this is the counsel I'm getting Oh ride
or dies your girls that love me
apparently they invited me to dress this
[ __ ] baby shower and these are the
man telling need to get go get a bigger
dick knowing you've got some more dick
like big man big man you're telling go
see cuz I'm lame it's old Amanda why are
you spreading my secret why are you
spreading my secret color I'm at the
baby shower
I'm the Jester the baby shower brother
the whole crew know I got a small bin
that's banter it's not the whole crew
knows not [ __ ] fair that she's
looking for a side man with a tall will
[ __ ] toolbox ahh bra ah you man a
South order no wonder Chris Brown said
he's hos ain't loyal they're not you man
are funny funny they're not loyal
but it's same time same time same say
I'm not mad at it I'm not I'm not the
games game the game is the game is the
game is the game game game this game bro
you have to take the Helzer w's where
exactly said everyone I can't be a win
and yo maybe that's the answer if you've
got a small dick maybe just firm that
your girl's a cheat and hopefully she
respects you enough that you're not
suspicious that of it
no that's I hear about that's mad
because you said three episodes ago you
said if you can you know I'm gonna say
yeah I know you just for context guy if
girls if you want a faithful man get a
guy for a small dick but man just said
if you got a smoother you girls know
Jake you're guilty in so your life is
long yeah why living embodiment of a
catch-22 you know I mean yeah so if you
got a small dick you're gonna be the
faithful one and she's gonna be cheating
she's gonna be out in looking for
schlong and her breads are gonna back
her of course they are mad of course
they are mad and you know what's funny
you know what's [ __ ] funny about that
your bread you say the the friends are
gonna back her yeah I've been in
relationships before and obviously I'm
having a laugh I've told I've had
confidence in my my girlfriend that
she's gang in it but she knows that I'm
about the relationship but what the what
my single boys are doing us what they're
doing so whenever I'll be like ah few
heads like who guys out here and know
what your giggling and I'm just uh yeah
if you had obviously just bang one girl
everyday this [ __ ] spikes this is why
I hate when you go out with your [ __ ]
friends your [ __ ] friend you told
your friend to go get a guy with a big
dick
what is this gone well I can't say the
name I can't say the name but a girl you
know that's day and that's comedy day
and I live it with someone
oh I know fun yeah yes fine I don't even
know if I told you so
yeah there's a girl I know that's
currently in a committed relationship
I'm living with someone he gives [ __ ]
dick to the point where she does she's
just given up on orgasms fun she's just
given up on orgasms but he's the perfect
guy like he treats her good he brings
money into the house like he's he's good
with kids like he brings around the
family like he's a good wholesome guy in
love
[ __ ] love sighs a real man yeah and
yeah but he's just not he's just not
about a sex like he's not you look at
him and in stature and kind of he's just
you you don't if I was a woman I
wouldn't look at him and be like I want
to [ __ ] that guy and you know you're not
gonna go yeah he ain't [ __ ] anyone
he's having sex intercourse yeah he's
having biological sex he's not [ __ ]
anyone so um this woman was it was
suggested in jest that this woman go get
a side man and then she went out and
approached the side man not thinking
that this side man was actually a guy
with a heart as well in it yeah so she
didn't hit him she didn't hit him with
what it was supposed to be that's the
[ __ ] difference
yeah when I'm saying if a girl texts me
saying yo I love my man but I need some
big dick to just give me what I need and
an asset yeah I'm gassed and I know what
the playing field is obviously she hit
him up she didn't want to sound like a
slag and so she didn't say that she
didn't say I'm looking for a sign man
with a big dick can you handle that yeah
you just started chatting to man she
said she will meet man for a drink she
said all this so then when she got cold
feet almost like one my doing I love my
man and backed out my man's [ __ ]
leavin notes on her car and [ __ ] he's
driving from London to where she lives
to leave a note in a car like hit me
back all this stuff we can solder fam
but didn't I tell you that you went
crazy crazy was been in a line non-stop
Oh coming to the yard leaving like
didn't didn't knock on the door anything
like that but leave a notes on our car
is [ __ ] like that right in her he wrote
her a letter and put in a post it was
like six pages back front and back what
love nuts so ladies did you get inside
man telling what the playing field is
because some guys are [ __ ] crazy and
every guy would be lucky and happy if
you just tell him what it's a post dear
yeah every guy will be [ __ ] happy
that's why I said earlier fam
don't make me open up what's up and see
if you're online just tell me tell me
who's on one night off tell me that it
was just dick and you had a good time
yeah and I can live a happy life from
there yeah but don't let me think like
date this doing that busy here busy
there
for them to be like just disappointed
tell me it's just there can I can live a
happy [ __ ] life
that was funny though yeah that was
funny
every song we've done I've laughed James
brah female perspective is so funny
I need more messages because it's just
you lost scum you know [ __ ] godless
scum
you're scum in private like yeah
mandemus come on road yeah yeah
but girls are scum in private mmm random
point actually as you just mentioned
Scott me in private mmm I just want to
break down like when I said there's like
there's such a divide yeah there's a few
kind of eternal what the I don't know
what the word is I'm looking for is
[ __ ] word would she say when it's
like a myth like his uh there's a few
rumors in that there's a few rumors i
sama sometimes I somehow such an idiot I
like to I like to pride myself on like
vocabulary and like having good
linguistics and sometimes I'm money like
rumors reinforcement I can't speak so
yeah like there is like a rumor going
around it's not even a rumor that's not
the word I'm looking for
it's like a it's like a myth mmm that
girls think when the girls say basically
you know I mean when girls say are guys
it's alright for guys to go around it
it's alright for guys to go around and
be slags and they give the players and
they get all the props and stuff like
that but when a girl does it they get
called a slag who are they referring to
because I've never called a girl a slag
in my entire life and if a girl's out
here trying to get it I'm about it I'm
about to give it I'm about it you're not
gonna get any disrespect from me yeah I
have nothing but positive things to say
about a woman that's about to come round
and just let out work who are these
where are these folklore this tale where
these vicious lies coming
my mum deceive you fam if you want a
buster Oprah if you wanna trust me if
you want to be a slide you're not gonna
hear a guy say your ass like unless
you've told him you love him and you
need it and then
just out here [ __ ] then you're gonna
get quarters like yeah that's different
but the fam if you just if you earn it
and you just a girl that likes to go out
and [ __ ] guys yeah you're not gonna hear
a negative thing from a guy not from a
guy that the girls might chat [ __ ]
probably this is part 2 da this is
exactly what I was gonna say anytime
when they say are you get called ass leg
girls say that yeah other [ __ ] ghosts
yeah all the vicious things that are
said about women I say upset by other
women 100 percent is a percent what's
even what mad is that they judge you off
the bat like I walk into work and I see
girls and look at other girls and just
judge them on what their way straight
girls are so just so quick to judge I'm
so quite judged so spiteful like a group
of girls could walk in and it could be a
group of girls sat somewhere else and it
all in a man's lap I and I and I on
because they now feel like they're not
the best-looking ones in the building
I'm like who gives a [ __ ] who gives them
Adam don't look at man don't be like
these [ __ ] guys yes my not Rudi's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] idiot you don't even look
that nice why is he wearing that shirt
cares no one gives a flying [ __ ] anyone
I'm a seven billion people anyone can
get oh you're still buff family you're
still paying women you like you're not
overcomplicate overcomplicated no one
actually cares that much right yeah yeah
the go if your hair in your name is a
your ass like your ass like it's cuz
other femurs have spread that yeah big
man if man dem are happy to [ __ ] you
they're not calling you a [ __ ] because
they're happy to boss or not probably
they're happy for it I'll never forget I
always give this go rate is go go from
uni oh god you know I'm talking about it
she owned it brav she owned oh my gosh
she owned it she didn't give a [ __ ]
that's unless she was up for anyone who
was down
rough disco boy funny funny girl fine
she's married with a kid now as well I
remember you telling me I sorta
Instagram the other day you tell me yeah
well she is she got married like
whenever come with me whenever when I
told you and then this year I see like I
think about last week I seen on
Instagram she had a kid um white kid as
well surprising she got her jollies from
the black guys and they just settled
down with a nice wholesome Caucasian but
yeah this girl she owned it man and I
gave nothing but props I think the time
yeah the time that sticks in my mind the
most is that we were a night out I
hadn't said two words to this girl we
were in the chicken shop afterwards she
said my fat she came up to me I know and
said my taxis here you come in come in I
remember of course I'm coming
of course yes yes I dropped my chicken
and a bounce like firm I gave my chili
sauce the next man and I said cool cool
and then a bus and Anna ran a bus mother
got dressed
I ran the [ __ ] home Jesus oh that was
funny bunny boy yeah don't be worried
man if you want there's no such thing as
a slag out here it's just other girls
being [ __ ] guys really don't care
we don't care unless we need you and we
love you then please for the love of God
don't do that please if you're single
knew trying to mingle birth mingle
mingle man do what's best for you you
like you only have one life man if you
want to bang bang cuz when you get
married and you're gonna be that
faithful press you only gonna bang one
man for 4050 years are you sure are you
sure fun if you wanna have fun have fun
outside to tell you otherwise have fun
have fun
ah more power no power to heal power to
you life listen [ __ ] it dump your man
and be a slag oh you man a single now
[ __ ] it we said human a single now you
like man apart in relate
they just get busy man oh [ __ ] best [ __ ]
oh that's funny I've laughed today yes a
my head hurts man
[ __ ] we still got some time huh
I think it's something I wanted to say
to you I literally can't remember oh
yeah so it's kind of just just a riff on
what we were saying before when Chloe
was here is that you man you were
listening
tell your friends to listen fam so this
needs to take off cuz I don't want to
work anymore oh god yeah yeah I don't
want to work and not saying that this
isn't work because people really don't
know I spend a lot of [ __ ] time
editing this [ __ ] yeah and getting out
there so yeah this is still work but
it's worth I want to do enjoyable yeah
I'm doing it for free now yeah it's not
work it's just what it is but I don't
want to work anymore I'm adding up a bit
yeah yeah I'm [ __ ] tired of it bro I
hate working bro
I [ __ ] hate work it's hiring it is
tiring it's ice so tiring especially
what I do is it's higher I can do we do
I know you say it's me I told you just
third world law week you tell me week in
week out it's tiring roll I haven't had
a weekend off with our requests than it
in six years without requesting it in
six years
that's my adult career Wow
I know 9 to 5 is as much as I say that
like I love what I do but I couldn't
never go back to work in the mines 5 I
remember I did my little spin in
Deloitte they [ __ ] fired me he can't
[ __ ] Deloitte but 9 to 5 is oh it's long
you know what I can't I'm not more
important I can't wake our eye before
this job office this is my first
nine-to-five
I'm from so from yeah backstory I've
gone from being a PT yeah originally and
that's ours all over the gaff yeah could
those hours I couldn't take anymore and
then I went into sales
yeah which the hours were bad but again
they're a bit all over the place yeah
and I needed a nine-to-five so I've got
a 9 to 5 and for the first couple of
months it's been alright yeah now it's
been best part of almost a year now
yeah and [ __ ] hell I want to put a
bullet in my head some days I wake up
recently recently I wake up and I'm just
[ __ ] sad yeah I look outside it's
dark outside I'm cold
I work the other day and he was just
pitch black wake up pitch black I'm
freezing I'd go out soon come I'm gonna
have to start scraping my car I get in
the steering wheels cold and I'm just
like why am I doing this bro like I'm
doing this so that I can drive an hour
to work oh my god to sit at my desk and
chat [ __ ] to clients on the phone and
[ __ ] do boring meetings yeah and
[ __ ] the negativity in an office firm
from these four year old [ __ ] the
negativity that day out from these
people brother is insane and like he's
terrifying
yeah I can't I can't bear it anymore
yeah like I get so depressed yeah I need
to leave and the thing is just like the
thing is what I was talking about is
that I've had jobs that I've loved yeah
and I [ __ ] hate them
yeah I hated them because I would still
wake up yeah regardless if I spotted a
one I just rushed out 5 a.m. or sad
midday if I talk to outside 9 like every
single one no matter how much I love
that job I would wake up and I fly [ __ ]
this yeah [ __ ] this brother I hate [ __ ]
why do we have to do it I know
ran over work is long and I know a lot
of people I like that but they just have
to bite the bullet go to what get that
money yeah man but yeah I'm working and
doing what you want to do is where it's
at yeah if you have a goal in mind it's
a lot easier yeah of course of course
since we've started doing this lot
easier for me to go to work yeah when
you're just in the abyss hmm and you're
just working because you have to work
you kind of angle yeah and it's like oh
if I do this on my goodness promotion
but I don't even want that promotion
anyway yeah it would just pay anymore
yeah
it's just the aspect of the money yeah
mm-hmm I don't want to [ __ ] do it
I hear you man mmm oh bryce long i just
so sick and tired of it I need to quit
but I can't you can't I can't if I quit
I'm I can't live it
yeah compy bills shower in the morning
if I quit it's long funny yeah man so
[ __ ] work you like just everyone listen
just listen to it don't even don't even
listen to it for that I could just
download it just download it it's
download fellas have you get the [ __ ]
hours subscribers my subs up so he's not
meant to be and make you laugh yeah yeah
then obviously it's all good
it's all gravy from there you it
download it follow the Instagram page
give us some likes give us some travel
so we can quit will be happy and they
will keep doing this forever I'm gonna
keep it forever anyway but more often
yeah [ __ ] you know it's funny
mmm and just just so you these [ __ ]
get clear yeah doing these is not easy
it's a lot for us to do this I have to
drive three hours to [ __ ] in Manchester
yeah to stay here for two days so we can
record like four EPS or three or
whatever yeah and then go home do my
[ __ ] alive until I can find another time
two or three hours and [ __ ] come here
again so yes no often I think yeah there
is an end game
no man think I think I've got all off my
chest it was so funny it was a funny
Appiah self a side man do what's right
engage self aside man I think that
should be the caption I oh yeah
tayo tayo tayo and a girls can't even
complain now cuz they
Miguel said that God did [ __ ] say it
hey we're not the victims no we're not
the [ __ ] whatever is we are the
victims the other victims we are the
actual victims not the suspects were the
victims yeah bro all right let me look
it off